All right. We have gotten to the end to some
degree of the Trump defamation and rape trial
brought by Jean Carroll. We now have video of
Trump's deposition. It is as crazy as anything
I have ever seen. Here is an unbelievable moment.
I would dare say Kafkaesque. Trump has long held.
One of the reasons he would not have sexually
assaulted Jean Carroll is not that he doesn't
sexually assault women. It's that she's not
his type. That's about physical attraction.
In this video. I'm about to play for you. This
is unbelievable. Trump is given a picture of Jean
Carroll and he believes that it's his ex-wife,
Marla maples, someone he presumably was attracted
to completely destroying. The notion that Jean
Carroll is not someone that is Trump's type.
He thought it was his own ex-wife. Take a look
at this. I don't even know who the woman. Let's
see. I don't know who. It's Marla. Okay. It's
Marla means it's my ex-wife, Marla maples.
You shake marbles in the photo? That's Marla.
Yeah, that's. That's my wife. Which one? Are
you putting something out here that you just
pointed to was always Carol version. And the
person with the woman on the right is your then
wife. I don't know. This was the picture. I assume
that's John Johnson. Is that. That's correct,
because it's very blurry. There you go. Trump
insists by and again, I I'm I'm not focusing on
the insanity of being accused of having sexually
assaulting someone and then saying they're not
my type. The right reaction from someone who
doesn't commit sexual assault would be I've
never sexually assaulted anyone and I don't
sexually assault people anyway. It's not a type,
except it sort of seems like she was because he
thought it was his own ex-wife. That is wild, wild
stuff. And somehow the people defending Biden,
we're supposed to believe are creepy in some
way. We then get to the next section about this,
about she's not my type. It wouldn't be my first
choice. And Trump, I think in this clip, he also
tells the lawyer, asking him the questions that
she wouldn't be a top choice for Trump either.
Look at this. When you said in that video
that misleads would not be your first choice,
you were referring to her physical looks.
Correct? Just the overall not. I look at her,
I see her. I hear what she says. Whatever.
You wouldn't be a choice of mine either,
to be honest with you. I hope you're not insulted.
I would not, under any circumstances, have any
interest in you. I'm being. I'm honest when I
say it. She I would not have any interest in.
When you say grotesque stuff. Grotesque stuff.
Trump wouldn't be interested in misleads or Jean
Carol or the lawyer asking the question. He's
just not interested. The good news, per Trump
is if he doesn't find you attractive, he wouldn't
sexually assault you. Of course, I would be much
more inspired if Trump were to say, It doesn't
matter how attractive I find someone. I would
never commit an act of sexual assault. That's not
what he has chosen to say. Trump also challenged
the timeline of the infamous Access Hollywood
tape, where he talks about when you're famous,
they just let you do it. You can grab them by the
you know what? Trump asked about whether he was
engaged to Melania at different points in time
and whether that would make that video more or
less problematic or whatever. Trump just basically
plays dumb and says, I don't remember when I was
married. I don't remember when I was engaged. I
don't know. Am I correct? That video was recorded
September 25. I guess that would I don't know the
date, but whatever date it was is fine with me.
And am I correct that you were engaged to your
current wife sometime in 2004? I don't know.
Am I correct that you married your current wife
in January 2005? I don't know. Relative to that
tape now, I doesn't know when he was married.
Now he's trying to get out of it by saying,
I don't know when the marriage happened
relative to that tape. But I mean, listen,
I'm not married. Don't most people remember
when they got married? Is that a crazy thing
to think you would remember? I don't know.
Married people can write to me and let me
know. The topic of the Access Hollywood tape did
come up multiple times. Here's another moment of
that in this video. I just started kissing them.
It's like a magnet. Just kiss. I don't even wait.
And when you're a star, they let you do
it. You can do anything. Grab them by. You
could do anything. That's what you said. Well,
historically, that's true with stars. Trump's
a historian here. That's all he meant. He just
meant from the point of view of a history buff.
When you're famous, they just let you do it. You
can grab them by the you know what? It's true with
stars that they can grab women, but. Well, that's
what if you look over the last million years
and years, million years ago to that over the
last million years, 250,000 of which it was modern
humans, and then before that, even in pre-human
times, you could just when you were a star,
pre-human stars, you know, 750,000 years ago, they
would just let you do it. It started to I started
thinking to myself, They're talking about stars
and Trump's talking about a million years. Is it
possible Trump's talking about actual stars like
out in space and this is actually about something
totally different. Let's go back. Uh, for the
last million years, Trump weighs in on human
history. Let's listen. It's true with stars that
they can grab women, but, well, that's what if you
look over the last million years, I guess that's
been largely true. Not always, but largely true,
unfortunately. Unfortunately, that's that's an
even crazier little book. And fortunately or
unfortunately, I guess it depends on the eye
of the beholder, who is doing the grabbing
and who's being grabbed for a million years.
When you're a star, they just let you do it.
This guy is out of his mind, truly. Now, just for
contrast, here's the one clip of this nonsense
that Fox News played, which quite frankly, is
like they found the only 30 seconds where Trump
doesn't seem as grotesque. Listen. I didn't have
to reach out to anybody because it didn't happen.
And by the way, if it did happen, it
would have been reported within minutes
talking about going to a major flaw.
Probably I assumed the most important flaw,
a major flaw in a major department store.
That's a very busy store, by the way. Right. And
checkout counters and everything else. And I would
be in there. I mean, it's the most ridiculous.
It's the most ridiculous, disgusting story. It
was just made up. Now, two things. One, Fox News
picking the clip. They skip all the grabbing by
the you know what? They skipped Trump telling
the lawyer he's not attracted to her, which
is crazy. And they picked this one clip where
Trump seems more defiant about just it's all made
up. The funny thing is, even this clip isn't that
great for Trump if you understand the full story,
because Trump has insisted as part of his defense,
he never would really go to that store. Bergdorf
Goodman He just he's not super familiar with it.
He never went there. Bah bah bah bah bah. But
he knows about the crowds and he knows about
which floors are the most important floors, which
would have the biggest crowds. Even this clip to
the No Wing Observer contradicts the story Trump
has been telling over and over and over and over
again. So the deposition video is bonkers cuckoo
for Cocoa Puffs stuff. The both sides have rested.
We will see what ultimately comes
of this defamation and rape trial.
But if you understand the back story,
Trump doesn't exactly look good here